[Applause]
how you doing Bernadino some folks down
at the Piggly Wiggly in the produce
section real upset you've been there
yeah you've been there you see anything
while you were down there
I've even been there for 70 year 70
years old yeah I've been there probably
I was there 70 years ago I don't know
you were there at the Piggly Wiggly 70
years ago Wow yeah that's a long time
for 20s afternoon think our produce
section area with fruits and vegetables
gentlemen Caucasian about 510
rollerskates which made us think maybe
it's Terry maybe Terry would know that
got to marry the person I work starts
dipping ugly see it see it seems again
to me like you might know this person in
the produce section I feel I don't know
any back I don't know any fat women with
red hair in the produce section all
right so this shifting are starting too
far witness Kelly Oubre
little thing and she wasn't super nice
wasn't super nice but maybe you got off
on the wrong foot because what were you
doing the produce section
I was trying fruit on mm-hmm that's
exactly that's exactly what we see let
him go and be you can skate yeah that's
Oh Mitch go